[Music]
in North ear news hi snot and get a [ __ ]
Mount apakah submitted by your worst
your worst enemy and they said that
worse is worse too [ __ ] dumb for
worse just kidding
so the dictionary oh I like that one I
only saying because you were calling us
enemies this subway worker that rid of a
robber with the commas response ever ah
subway as in the chainage subway as in
case I know how to do it easy how grab
one of the scale a presence Mac Olympia
wait [ __ ] Bob we want to sponsor us
you do not a big - it daily another
mystery face bring the bread is supposed
to be fresh and it's so bad well you
know what though I get this I get
processed subway because if you want
something that fits your macros their
subway is the [ __ ]
and if [ __ ] it fills you up and on top
of that it helps like yeah if you can't
digest to fill a spread but check it out
so here's the thing on top of that - it
helps you fill up your [ __ ] micro
nutrition - because you could stack it
with hell of a genius you know what I go
there for like chicken breast but I
leave with an Italian [ __ ] cold cut
combo that's terrible I know you go
there for those [ __ ] weird chicken
breasts that's not even real chicken
whatever but then I'd leave with
something else all the time monkey LLC
and I get the meatball sandwich oh hell
yeah nothing wrong just a second after
you [ __ ] you said right now man I know
that these are nasty ass Oh
signed up so Jersey Mike's I love Jersey
yesterday like dude that [ __ ] club
sandwich at Jersey Mike's and you get a
Mike's way dude it's so [ __ ] good
managers 'man i'm going to post makes it
did they buy out Quiznos that's the one
I love the most because the locations
that used to be Quiznos they're all like
Jersey Mike's now I don't know if
they're completely gone it's because the
only thing that was clubbing of Quiznos
was the fact that you could toast your
[ __ ] but the subway started doing that
too and
prices were more competitive and Quiznos
wasn't even as good as Subway they were
on the same par so it was dead in subway
yeah because they can heat it but not
the subway so no subways what's the
other one was it Quiznos
logos total is good I've never tried
with us that's the one that I like them
total is good they're on a different
part though
oh wait that's what I'm thinking - yes I
mean I love okay I meant Togo's sorry
yeah me too I totally mix it up and I'm
never tired really my parents really
Mike it's just like good like just deli
sandwich how supposed to be you can
toast it - well you can't even ask them
to warm it up and oh yeah we'll just put
it on the grill for you ok let's
continue with this art anyways so this
takes place in Ohio and Wow there was
these two women working in subway so the
girl that was at the cash register
she is confronted by this man that comes
in that's like covered his face the
hoodie cigarette enjoy all the dancer
either dancer a dentist and so he's
demanding her to open the register and
open the [ __ ] register and then
cheese you have to cause what someone's
a robber is always being so mean what
would a [ __ ] [ __ ] do that [ __ ] like
why can't you just you're already
putting a gun on someone just be polite
sleep please can you open your register
please can you please open the rest
receptor goody
you tried gotta be made so it hasn't
been reported if he had a weapon but I
was reading some comments and there was
comments saying like what he had no
weapon I don't know where they got that
information with I'm doing my thing he
had no weapon anyway so you should start
the knowledge salami ninja stars on the
pepper Cheney they should [ __ ] plan
yeah so then the girl that wasn't at the
counter she she pulled out her cell
phone and she started recording this
whole interaction
it said 1991 she's trying to go viral
worldstar know so this is the second
time that there's no way I gotten wrong
all come on it's not the first time it
happened so they're you know what to do
damn broad daylight
hold on I get a job he walks away so
when the video stops recording
he ended up walking away with the tip
Charlotte when we had $13 what a [ __ ]
face man how did she know that he was
just too [ __ ] Robert I think which it
seems that she is something that
happened frequently because she goes are
you the guy that's been robbing blah
blah blah so she already knew that he
didn't have a weapon could even have one
before so he was just being intimidating
and saying open the register and she is
pretty that's another reason why people
are coming to handle weapon because some
people are brave though they're like
you're not going to kill me she was the
one at the counter she has that face
like I'm bonus [ __ ] she does she does
look like tough like yeah today my god
I've seen [ __ ] like she just told the
story like I wanted fun cuz of that
battle believe it yes she was in the
interview she was kind of like that like
very like I know I shouldn't be doing
these stupid things but sometimes there
discover that it's just I got games in
my blood what can I say
he's like the tough one and that's her
like psychic like yup yup like her - you
know like yeah I was there with her
without recording it all is about I kind
of scared the block she looks up to her
like she's like the alpha one that is my
hero that's my big sister yo she hold
the [ __ ] down with Omar - bread in
effect I told her that a job it's gonna
be one of those stories that she just
tells forever she's gonna be an old
grandma there was a man that came up and
I told him just get a job and he got
away
she should be manager now I'm trying to
manage that store if it keeps on being
robbed slug that and I'm trying to go
work at a [ __ ] Quiznos yeah so her
name is Kathy the girl that was
recording her name is Sierra so Kathy
was saying in her interview quote I
guess sometimes I do things I shouldn't
do and I speak just whatever comes to my
mind she's a lot of people are saying
that like Nashville
Ravan courageous because you never know
what could happen in and Sierra was
saying like I was so scared like in the
video you need to see like I was kind of
trembling so scared I didn't know what
he would do what he's capable of because
he could have just easily climbed over
the counter leakage I don't think that's
true but she look like she could she got
hands oh she's probably got the sixth
sense you know how some people are like
you ain't gonna do [ __ ] I feel like in
my situation though I would always
assess with the knack of this [ __ ] and
most likely you have that except I saw
the [ __ ] did you have where'd you take a
shotgun much pretty big what did that
come from there they're saying the way
that they describe this man is that he
has blue and he's a white man he had
blue glistening eyes it was very mannish
you just see into your soul
I heard Ohio's kind of get although why
people get old I heard there's a lot of
that's where Dave Chappelle's friend
Juggalo looking peoples what's a Juggalo
yeah those uh ICP lovers with a insane
clown posse people huh yeah Juggalos the
bottles are called jugglers Oh didn't
they paint their face clowns I like even
now then you they were around like in
the early 2000 I remember that moment
Indiana and Ohio supposedly by wishing
Machine Gun Kelly father or Thai people
yeah he's like the modern-day version of
that are we love the clown I guess like
a Midwest white rapper it's like the
Midwest hip-hop crowd it is insane
composit yeah so all the Juggalos look
like that kind of a Chinese opera theme
yeah I don't think I've ever followed a
musician so hard that I wouldn't walk
around looking like a dumb [ __ ] like I
don't think that's gonna be my [ __ ] I
mean I love you so much I wanna [ __ ]
more my self esteem God yeah but
supposedly that's like the super ghetto
place so be careful here's another one
your kid
yeah where do you even go to find
clothes like that Walmart that's great
yet I don't it could be like Walmart Hot
Topic put together and a SWOT me you
know what these people represent me or
like this picture reminds me of it
reminds me of those guys that you see
through YouTube videos
cutting [ __ ] with swords all the time
how if you look up white guy cutting
swords is always a white person that's
400 pounds
well yeah you looked up white guy yeah
but they're always poor bill I know it's
video you're talking about it's like
this really big dude is that just one
though there's like a really a different
guy to look just like him and they're
always like insanely overweight and made
you sit there just I know what I'm
talking about when I was in Boy Scouts
our Scoutmaster son was one of those
guys but there when you're like eight
and if this was a grown-ass man are the
ton of swords and knives think he's like
the coolest guy in the world and when
we're hanging out camping he's always
trying tribal on napkins and so he would
always draw like tribal for one kid and
give him to another kid no we would get
o course is so cool of the curve black
design that kid that kills pie like 19
or 20 years old oh my god tribal on
napkins all the time and when he get
older like that pull the straight loser
yeah
Mondrian I was like eight or nine you
know if you're good
no because he's the Scoutmaster son
it'll come can't be with us that's still
a loser yeah well we're a kid like
you're like oh man look at how he's like
you had all these weird knives that
don't really work in the force they'll
be like this is a nice from Star Trek
and here's this other Prohm knife from
like this movie you like spin it on his
finger and you're like when you're nine
of them wow I'm gonna get older my dad
was straight loser that's true and he
was like 350 pounds swinging knives
he always had a [ __ ] utility belt on
he always had like these black combat
boots even though we're like camping in
like some children's playground hope you
guys enjoyed that video but if you
didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the articles that we
discuss just cruise out over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click rat up hi
[Music]